bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'actif
sur tv fil 78 temps ce jeudi 3 octobre
le tour de l'actualité locale voici les
principaux titres de cette édition le
cumul des mandats les sénateurs ont voté
contre le mois dernier les députés vont
bientôt devoir s'exprimer à nouveau nous
verrons justement ce qu'en pense jean
philippe mallet député socialiste de la
11e circonscription des yvelines est
l'invité de cette édition le congrès des
parcs naturels se déroule en ce moment
en haute vallée de chevreuse affirmer
leur spécificité de défendre leur
territoire mais également avec un mot
d'ordre favoriser la transition
énergétique et le président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui dresse ses priorités
pour cette rentrée une année de
transition d'une construction pour
jean-luc baissière entre un
développement du futur ensemble paris
saclay et derniers préparatifs avant
l'ouverture d'un institut d'études
politiques à saint germain en laye à
l'image du jour c'est une image
artistique elle est signée felice varini
l'artiste qui vient de signer une
exposition géante au grand palais à
paris cette fois ce sont des cercles
rouges géant qui ornent les bâtiments
des petites écuries à versailles vous
les avez peut-être remarqué si vous vous
promenez du côté du potager du roi ils
sont donc l'oeuvre de ce plasticien
suisse
elles seront exceptionnellement illuminé
ce samedi à 5 octobre à l'occasion de la
nuit blanche à un travail de peinture
étonnant et si vous manquer ce rendez
vous de samedi soir l'exposition elle
dure jusqu'au 14 décembre
pour débuter cette édition nous allons
parler du cumul des mandats en plateau
ce soir jean philippe mallet député ps
de la 11e circonscription des yvelines
bonsoir à vous ils sont votre avis sur
ce dossier que votre et vous à
l'assemblée on va en parler dans un
instant mais déjà quelques précisions
sur le cumul avec ce reportage qui sont
les cumulards c'est comme ça qu'on les
appelle dans notre département l'ump
gérard larcher champions yvelinois du
cumul des mandats 31e au niveau national
sur 1573 élus selon l' enquête du
journal l'express
le sénateur des yvelines maire de
rambouillet occupe en marge de ces
mandats pas moins de sept fonctions de
la présidence du comité de l'office de
tourisme de rambouillet à la présidence
du conseil d'administration du domaine
national de chambord c'est donc sans
grande surprise qu'il s'oppose au projet
de loi du gouvernement sur le non cumul
même s'il anticipait déjà le texte en
renonçant à un nouveau mandat en mars
prochain
depuis trente ans je suis maire de
rambouillet depuis plus de 26 ans j'ai
été élu parlementaire je pense avoir pu
exercer ses deux fonctions
j'allais lire dans le respect de chacune
des fonctions et au contraire avoir
enrichi du mon expérience d'élu local
l'exercice de ma fonction nationale et
inversement
donc je combattrai ce texte lors du vote
du projet de loi par la chambre et
hôtels les sénateurs ont voté pour mais
en s'excluant du dispositif
ce sont donc les députés qui vont
décider lors d'une nouvelle lecture de
l'avenir de ce texte que le gouvernement
annonce présentée au nom de la
transparence publique et de la
moralisation de la vie politique
valérie pécresse et député ump de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines elle est
justement contre le cumul des mandats
mais demandent quelques ajustements ce
que je reproche au gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est de laisser les députés
sans j'allais dire l'équipe nécessaires
pour les aider les appuyer dans les
autres pays
un député c'est quelqu'un qui a un vrai
style une vraie équipe derrière pour
faire pour l'aider à faire des choses
des vrais moyens y compris financiers
pour faire bouger les choses
donc il faut faire le non-cumul mais il
faut revaloriser la fonction
parlementaire est donné aux
parlementaires des assistants et une
grecque
valérie pécresse qui dans le classement
de l'express figure à la 7 148e place à
la fois député des yvelines mais aussi
conseillère régionale d'île de france
parmi les autres élus du département on
retrouvera également françois de ligne
est lui aussi à la 740 huitième position
maire de guyancourt et conseiller
général
je suis contre le fait d'avoir deux
exécutifs parce que c'est trop lourd
savez mes responsabilités de maire je
les fais enfin je les assume entièrement
ça demande énormément de temps et quand
on est à l'agglomération ou quand c'est
général c'est pour porter des besoins du
territoire
c'est pour travailler dans l'intérêt des
habitants et les représenter par contre
être à deux exécutifs ça n'a jamais été
ma volonté
la loi sur le non-cumul des mandats sera
prochainement présenté au palais bourbon
et une majorité absolue sera nécessaire
pour entériner le texte qui rentreraient
en vigueur en 2010 est pour les
prochaines législatives
invité donc pour développer ce dossier
le député socialiste jean philippe
mallet pour faire et quoi ce palmarès de
l'express qui était évoquée dans le
sujet voici votre classement mille 41e
sur 1573 avec deux mandats député
conseiller général
quel regard vous portez sur ce dossier
du cumul des mandats est ce que vous
voterez contre le cumul des mandats à
l'assemblée moi je suis favorable
effectivement la limitation du cumul des
mandats
je suis d'ailleurs dans les pures du
projet de loi qui est très précisément
de d'interdire à tout parlementaires
députés ou sénateurs d'être dans un
exécutif local
donc je suis tout à fait favorable à
ceci pour plusieurs raisons la première
c'est que décemment on ne peut pas tout
faire on s'en rend compte
on ne peut pas être à la fois maire et
député matériellement c'est difficile
chacune de ces fonctions demande du
temps de l'engagement donc un
investissement personnel
et puis d'autre part il peut y avoir des
conflits d'intérêts lorsque vous êtes
maire d'une ville a fortiori d'une
grande ville mais que lorsque vous êtes
président d'un conseil général d'un
département ou d'une région
vous défendez c'est votre travail vous
défendez votre territoire
votre commune votre département votre
région or quand vous êtes député ou
sénateur voter la loi l'intérêt général
donc on n'est pas du tout dans la même
dans la même position il ya un constat
favorable au cumul des mandats on aurait
bien compris mais ça me fait trop tôt
est ce que c'est un texte qui va passer
à l'assemblée quand on voit que du côté
des sénateurs votent favorablement ont
dit oui effectivement faut limiter le
cumul mais on s'est exclu du dispositif
c'est ce qu'ont fait les sénateurs à
l'assemblée le texte va passer et va
concerner tout le monde sénateurs comme
les députés tout à fait in fine est
d'ailleurs manuel valls l'a rappelé
lorsqu'il a défendu le texte de ronde a
été sacré sur les zélateurs socialiste
est en fait il à la totalité pas la
totalité mais une majorité quand même
qui a des sénateurs socialistes qui a
voté le texte il a rappelé que in fine
et dans notre constitution ce sont les
députés qui ont le dernier mot
et donc ce texte sera voté c'est une
bonne chose
j'aurais souhaité avec un certain nombre
de jeunes députés qu'on aille plus loin
par exemple je suis très attaché à la
limitation dans le temps du cumul des
mandats je pense que quand on est maire
conseiller général député
quel que soit le mandat et qu'on fait
trois mandats successifs s'est très
nettement suffisant
nous voyons des des mères qui se
présentent à des âges canoniques
ce n'est pas sain je vois l'assemblée
nationale des députés qui sont élus
depuis 40 ans ce n'est pas sérieux ce
n'est pas sain donc je suis aussi
favorable ça n'est pas dans le texte
ça n'a pas été retenu mais ça sera je
l'espère en tous les cas nous nous y
militons avec un certain nombre de
jeunes députés pour favorable à ce que
ce soit parce qu'ils également plus tard
une limitation dans le temps des mandats
avant de rentrer au palais bourbon vous
étiez conseiller municipal à bois d'arcy
venoix hamon a été élu député vous étiez
son suppléant vous l'avait remplacé vous
siégez l'assemblée nationale du côté de
bois d'arcy le maire 81 ans va se
représenter claude juillet vous en avez
discuté avec lui puisque vous parliez de
limiter les mandats dans le temps et
limiter l'âge aussi alors forcément je
vous pose cette question concernant une
commune que vous devez suivre encore
aujourd'hui tout à fait je vis à bois
d'arcy j'ai beaucoup d'amis à bois
d'arcy vous rappelle que les arcisien
pour ces élections cantonales et
législatives m'ont fait confiance et
nous ont fait confiance à benoît hamon
et à moi même avait succédé à une large
majorité beaucoup d'art 6e parle des
municipales
si vous les jeux ce qui m'intéresse
c'est vraiment la question des principes
je ne souhaite pas je voulais évoquer
des deux noms personnes la seule
question que je pose c'est est-ce
sérieux de se présenter lorsqu'on a plus
de 80 ans une élection municipale elle
sérieux est ce sain d'être député depuis
depuis 30 ans 40 ans je ne pense pas et
donc c'est pour cette raison précise
qu'il faut poser des règles
l'homme étant ce qu'il est il faut que
l'on pose des règles de fonctionnement
qui soit qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
rigoureuses et pour l'instant ce qui
prime c'est le cumul des mandats c'est
la question que nous avons posée
aujourd'hui que pensez vous de l'idée
d'interdire le cumul des mandats vos
réponses lutte cotre accumule demande un
puisque
assez souvent les responsables
politiques est trop occupé il peut pas
stocker il n'a pas le temps de vraiment
se donner à high tech à quand une
personne ben cumul des mandats ça prouve
qu'elle est qu'elle est efficace
seulement contre parce que je pense que
déjà un mandat c'est bien alors cumulé
ça fait pourquoi je suis contre le cumul
des mandats
parce que je trouve que les gens qui
cumulent les mandats ils se font une
joie gagnent beaucoup d'argent quand
ceux ci on suit les principes que je
cumule les mandats en cumul les salaires
et que curieux et salaires lorsqu'on est
déjà suffisamment weyer riche with et
c'est un peu profité de ces faits qu'on
soit aux places et voilà pour vous
différentes réactions recueillies
aujourd'hui dans les rues de saint
quentin en yvelines les gens sont plutôt
opposés à 1,8 g mandat c'est parce qu'il
n'ya pas une unanimité non plus de la
classe politique d'un bord ou d'un autre
du côté des socialistes tout le monde
n'est pas contre le cumul des mandats
tout en vous le prenez vous en parlez
avec vos collègues socialistes également
vous comprenez aussi que les consignes
qu'ils soient donnés soient pas toujours
suivi on parlait tout à l'heure des
sénateurs avec le manuel valls qui n'a
pas été entendu par l'ensemble des
sénateurs socialistes
vous savez c'est le sénat un premier
ministre avait dit c'est une anomalie
démocratique le sait là je rappelle que
le sénat a contribué en son temps à la
chute de charles de gaulle qui a tant
apporté à la séance
c'est un des conservatoires du
conservatisme
et y compris malheureusement je le
regrette chez h et certains chez
certains élus sénateurs de gauche
malheureusement il n'y a pas d'unanimité
c'est ta question que je vous pose est
comment on peut expliquer qu'ils aient
pas d'unanimité que ce n'est pas ce les
clivages politiques cette question du
cumul mais parce que vous avez des
confusions
je pense que on l'a bien vu dans la
réaction des français savent bien que
confusion de 2,2 de valeur être mère
être député c'est pas un métier c'est
une fonction et on dit voilà dans une
période de sa vie
on a un métier mais on consacre une
période de sa vie au service
c'est une fonction au service de la
collectivité d'une commune ou de la
france quand on est député ou sénateur
les choses sont très simples ce sont les
les femmes et les hommes qui qui qui les
rendent qui rendent ces choses-là
compliqué je suis vraiment pour qu'on
comprenne les mesures de bon sens
fois de plus je pense pas qu'il soit
sain d'être d'être député depuis 30 ans
40 ans je pense pas qu'il soit sain
d'être de se présenter à une élection
municipale quand on a au delà de 80 ans
voilà je sais votre message je crois
qu'il a été clair et qu'on l'a bien
entendu on va juste écarté quelques
instants de cette question du cumul des
mandats on parler des différences de
points de vue au sein même du parti
socialiste vous remplacer benoît hamon
actuellement à l'assemblée nationale
puisqu'il était nommé ministre de
l'économie sociale et solidaire benoît
hamon qui a eu quelques échanges aussi
avec une autre ministre ans cécile
duflot manuel valls fait aussi partie de
ces différents échanges c'était au tour
de la question des roms
vous avez le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui il
ya des tensions au sein même du
gouvernement et quelles incidences ça
peut aussi avoir par la suite
ne serait ce que sur les élections
municipales aubin vous savez le
laborieux oeil vraiment une césure 1
entre les élections locales municipales
et le contexte national bon n'en demeure
pas moins que la voix du gouvernement
n'est pas forcément très très clair pour
l'opinion aujourd'hui bien sûr mais le
président je crois
a rétabli les choses a fait preuve
d'autorité a indiqué qu'ils ne
souffriraient plus qu'il y ait de tels
voilà deux de telle ou telle polémique
moi je considère de toute façon que la
république doit pouvoir et lorsque on
est élu on doit pouvoir s'attacher alors
dans la fermeté mais a intégré à mettre
en mettre en place les dispositions les
dispositifs qui doivent permettre à la
population de vivre selon selon nos lois
on ne doit pas on ne doit pas abandonner
ceux ci c'est une conception
républicaine que partager que partager
des élus de droite et de gauche
la conception républicaine gaulliste
aussi est d'une certaine façon la france
il faut jamais perdre de vue que la
france est une construction politique
c'est un projet d'intégration c'est un
vivre ensemble un plébiscite quotidien
disait ernest renan donc si on dit voilà
c'est que ces personnes ne peuvent pas
peuvent pas par nature s'intégrer à
notre pays
je pense que pour ce n'est pas vrai
c'est faux et puis c'est renoncer à ce
qui fait à ce qui fait notre engagement
et sa divise le gouvernement ça divise
aussi cette question là les socialistes
ou d'un à questions concernant
gouvernement concernant benoît hamon ce
qu'il a évoqué avec vous la possibilité
aussi de quitter le gouvernement
même après les municipales non c'est de
redevenir député
c'est pas de l'actualité parce que
certaines dont l'ont d'ailleurs un peu
un peu caricaturé mais vous avez vous
avez certainement remarqué depuis qu'il
est ministre il est d'une totale loyauté
solidarité vis-à-vis du gouvernement
il n'a jamais recherché la petite phrase
la polémique
il n'a pas souhaité se t il il travaille
il travaille au service de la france et
des français
jean philippe wahl et député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines socialiste
vous restez en plateau avec nous on va
évoquer un autre dossier brûlant
d'actualité c'est le travail le dimanche
la semaine a été agitée même si le
dossier n'est pas tout à fait nouveau
après l'injonction de justice de
fermeture le dimanche une quinzaine de
magasins de bricolage une obligation non
respectait le collectif des bricoleurs
composée de salariés à manifester devant
matignon hier on va écouter l'une des
porte-parole du collectif des bricoleurs
du dimanche elle travaille à bois d'arcy
elle a été reçu par le cabinet du
premier ministre et puis juste après
vous entendrez d'ailleurs la réaction du
ministre benoît hamon sur ce dossier on
s'est mobilisé pour obtenir de la part
du gouvernement un décret qui nous
permettrait d'ouvrir au même titre que
les magasins de jardinage et
d'ameublement
on ne demande pas une généralisation du
travail du dimanche on demande juste une
virgule de plus à jardinage ameublement
et bricolage voilà c'est tout ce qu'on
demande nouveau gouvernement à l'heure
actuelle comprend la demande qui existe
et qu'en l'occurrence en l'état de la
loi
justice prend ses décisions en grande
mais moi je suis pas là aujourd'hui pour
parler du travail de dimanche
je suis là pour parler des emplois qu'on
va créer des gens qui espèrent déjà
travaillé lundi mardi mercredi jeudi
vendredi
ce qui sera très très bien et avec un
salaire décent interview interview
réalisée du ministre lors de son
déplacement dans les yvelines pour la
signature de contrats d'avenir cet essai
dossier qui l'évoqué votre avis en tant
que député sur le travail le dimanche
oui il faut l'interdire battre éditrice
par mon engagement politique par mes
convictions philosophiques personnel je
suis opposé au travail au travail le
dimanche à la généralisation du travail
du dimanche c'est à dire je ne souhaite
pas que l'on généralise aux entreprises
et au secteur public le travail le
dimanche
vraiment et je tiens à des gens qui
veulent travailler et je compte environ
et je tiens à ce principe c'est ça la
réalité d'alluré envie suivant ce
principe alors évidemment il ya des
exceptions
chacun comprend bien que l'hôpital
secteur public doit travailler le
dimanche ça que chacun comprend bien que
les boulangers travail le dimanche mais
il ya eu un la nomination de monsieur
bailly qui doit réfléchir et moi
j'appelle de rivers cessera réflexion
sur on va dire une mise en cohérence
une mise en homogénéité une
rationalisation de ces exceptions
effectivement on ne comprend pas que des
magasins d'ameublement soit depuis de
nombreuses années ouverts le dimanche
il faut interdire sa base et paléo ces
noms et pas les magasins de bricolage
devrait plutôt autorisé aussi au magasin
pourquoi pas il faut du cas par cas sans
toi voilà je pense qu'il faut vraiment
réfléchir à cela
en considérant qu'un le principe c'est
on ne généralise pas le travail le
dimanche je suis totalement opposé
mais on met les exceptions je dirais
qu'on les met en cohérence ont réfléchi
à ces exceptions qui existent qui sont
nombreuses en france on essaie de les
rationnaliser quoi évidemment les gens
ne comprennent pas qu'on puisse aller
acheter des meubles le dimanche est pas
acheté pour pour les monter d'autant que
souvent les magasins sont ces magasins
sont pratiquement sur le même créneau
quoi ils vendent en partie les mêmes
produits donc c'est souvent voisins
aussi sera plan géographique ce n'est
pas cohérent
voilà donc j'appelle de mes voeux cette
mise en cohérence de de ces exceptions
pour merci jean philippe halley qui
était donc l'invité de cette édition du
journal des piliers de la 11e
circonscription
vous avez réagi notamment aussi à la
question du cumul des mandats on vous
entendu tout à l'heure et sachez aussi
que mardi soir à 18h30 le 7-8 société
sur tv fils émission de débat de la
rédaction il reviendra sur l'un d'eux
sur ce dossier justement avec des élus
de gauche de droite des salariés des
partisans des opposants au travail le
fameux dimanche ce fameux septième jour
de la semaine
la suite de ce dossier de la réforme des
rythmes scolaires pour vous préciser que
jean michel fourgous qui est à l'origine
d'une pétition contre la mise en place
de cette nouvelle disposition dès la
rentrée 2014 appelle aujourd'hui les
maires à boycotter la mise en place de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires et puis
politique toujours pour vous annoncer
qu'il ya un nouveau candidat du côté de
guyancourt après françois de l'ine le
maire sortant socialiste et puis
ladislas secouera pour l'ump c'est jean
loup cariat vous allez le voir
c'est donc lui qui représentera le modem
sur la ville de guyancourt en mars
prochain le nom de son mouvement
guyancourt en mouvement justement ce
sera le nom de sa liste
jusqu'au 4 octobre la fédération des
parcs naturels régionaux organise son
congrès 2013 dans la haute vallée de
chevreuse en plein débat sur la
transition énergétique les parcs veulent
changer les mentalités et les modes de
vie
anthony rech et jonathan willeman pour
ce reportage créé en 1985 le parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
comprend désormais 109 mille habitants
c'est un modèle vers le changement des
modes de vie à saint rémy les chevreuse
par exemple la première maison française
certifiée passive en rénovation vient
d'être construite
on travaille beaucoup sur des questions
de densification ou sur des concepts
tels que celui de bimbo bild et
une my backyard par opposition à not in
my backyard donc pas à pas dans mon
jardin
là en l'occurrence il s'agit de diviser
des parcelles pour pouvoir densifier de
façon intelligente mais sur l'aspect
mobilité le chemin est encore long
les habitants de parcs naturels sont de
mauvais élève
la part de ménages comptant deux
voitures ou plus est plus forte au sein
des pnr que sur le reste du territoire
si on ne modifie rien aux trajectoires
énergétique
il en coûtera 150 milliards de plus à la
france en 2050 et ce sont les
entreprises et les ménages qui les
perrons il faut donc s'engager dans
cette transition énergétique qui n'est
pas une punition mais qu'on contraire
une façon de faire gagner du pouvoir
d'achat aux gens à à long terme
si certains projets synonyme de
transition énergétique et écologique
sont en marche
les parcs naturels régionaux sont aussi
touchés par la crise la croissance de
l'emploi est légèrement plus faible qu
hors pnr on a des soucis c'est pato rose
dans les parcs 1 on a des problèmes
sociaux des problèmes de chômage et des
problèmes économiques que nos
agriculteurs
voilà mais on a une grande
responsabilité d'abord de protéger de
restaurer cette biodiversité
voilà et puis d'accompagner donc ces
territoires qui sont des territoires en
mouvement
pour atteindre ces objectifs de
biodiversité la fédération des pnr a
annoncé en ouverture du congrès faire
départ des zones autonomes en énergie
d'ici 2030 deux nouveaux parcs dans
l'essonne et en seine et marne sont
allés piller le parc de la mgen la
mutuelle générale de l'éducation
nationale désormais accessible à tous
les verrières roi une convention a été
signée ce mercredi entre le président de
la mgen et le maire de la ville de la
verrière alain ajaj dès la fin du mois
elle les habitants vont donc pouvoir
profiter de cet espace boisé de 15
hectares auparavant il n'était réservé
qu'aux patients et au personnel de
l'établissement yolaine 13 elodie mois
un espace de 15 hectares pour tous les
habitants de la verrière c'est le
résultat de la convention signée ce
mercredi à la mairie
le parc de la mgen et bientôt accessible
à toute la population
je pense en particulier aux enfants qui
depuis longtemps devait avoir envie de
courir dans ce parc de construire des
cabanes d'aller voir les daims c'est
désormais possible
on est très heureux de pouvoir le faire
avec monsieur le maire et avec la
municipalité puis ça renforce les liens
entre la mgen 4 des établissements
importants sur cette commune et puis la
ville de la verrière
dès la fin du mois les habitants
pourront profiter de cet espace pour de
nouvelles promenades deux entrées sont
actuellement en cours d'aménagement dont
celle ci avenue de montfort bah ouais si
c'est ouvert
bah ouais avec les enfants malades ça
fait un peu d'animation dit sorti tous
ça peut me de cette 10e et 11e peu d'air
c'est beau le parc fonctionnera d'abord
avec des heures d'ouverture et de
fermeture et à plus long terme des
projets seront étudiés parmi eux
l'installation d'un parcours santé et
l'aménagement d'une ferme pédagogique
le président de l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
tenait donc ce matin sa conférence de
presse de rentrée 2014 sera une année de
transition de construction se sont elles
ces termes il faut dire que le
rapprochement avec l'université de paris
saclay n'a jamais semblé aussi proche le
futur établissement paris saclay verra
le jour officiellement en avril 2014
il va travailler en étroite
collaboration avec les différentes
facultés yvelinoise regroupés derrière
le sigle de l'ue vs qu lui vécu qui ne
va pas disparaître pour autant tout du
moins dans un premier temps non c'est
pas la disparition d'un 16h51 divine au
contraire je pense qu'il monte en
puissance d'une entité grâce à son
intégration dans cet ensemble il ya
vraiment un beau projet avec de la mise
en oeuvre de synergies salaires pouvoir
faire ensemble ce qu'on n'est pas
capable de faire tout seul
donc avec de faire des beaux projets de
formation également de recherche de
formation aux étudiants donc qui
permettra également d'améliorer la
qualité de la formation d'opposition
mais également d'être plus attractif au
niveau international après on peut
envisager un recrutement encore un peu
plus étroit d'une certaine catégorie
d'établissements que les universités du
projet fusionnent et qu'il ne reste plus
donc université paris saclay avec des
des composantes fin d'une faculté de
droit une faculté de médecine qui serait
le regroupement des facultés droits de
ces paris sud et de
versailles-saint-quentin faculté
médecine aussi recommandé 2 voilà
également dans cette nouvelle mesure six
pieds on aurait des des écoles internes
comme polytechnique ou hec qui
conserverait une marche pas d'autonomie
projet la création d'un institut
d'études politiques avec l'université de
cergy pontoise il accueillera ses
premiers étudiants à
saint-germain-en-laye 80 environ à la
rentrée 2014 nous en avons d'ailleurs
déjà parlé sur notre antenne pour
l'instant en cette rentrée 2013 ce sont
vingt mille cinq cents étudiants et qui
sont inscrits à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin des étudiants
qui peut être dans les prochaines années
subiront des tests de sélection à
l'entrée de la licence ou du moins un
accompagnement actif
l'université se doit aussi d'être
attractive au regard des étudiants qui
aujourd'hui choisissent d'autres
filières filières sélectives je peux
parler des classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles
mais je peux également parler de toutes
les écoles qui existent en programmes
intégrés sur cinq ans des écoles de
qualité très diverses
donc c'est de pouvoir ramener vers
l'universitaire ramener vers les
licences c'est clair c'est la licence
dont il est question aujourd'hui les
étudiants qui arrivent avec une certaine
difficulté augmente on doit pouvoir
accompagner peut-être faire une licence
encadrant avec une année zéro
par contre les étudiants plus mieux armé
scolairement plus motivés qu'ils
connaissent mieux le système
on pourrait par exemple proposer de
faire une licence en deux ans ou de
faire une licence avec déjà une activité
d'initiation forte à la recherche ou de
leur proposer des cursus plus dense avec
pluri disciplinaire on change de sujet
on parle culture avant de refermer ce
journal la maison de la poésie qui
célèbre le centenaire du poète et
écrivain yvelinois jean rousselot
exposition présentée jusqu'au 19 octobre
reportage lors il ya des lissiers de
patrick jane
il aurait eu 100 ans cette année jean
rosselot écrivain et poète heavy noire
décédé en 2005 fut l'une des voies
essentielles de la poésie et de la
critique littéraire du 20e siècle
à l'occasion de son centenaire la maison
de la poésie et la médiathèque de
guyancourt qui porte son nom lui
consacre une exposition jusqu'au 19
octobre
en le lisant on se rend compte que
c'était un poète une grande grande
humanité mais avec un regard très
acérées très très critique vis-à-vis
l'humanité mais en même temps un fol
espoir dans cette humanité là donc c'est
une sorte de paradoxe qu'il entretenait
naturellement il se forçait pas du tout
voilà une grande lucidité sur le monde
sur l'état du monde sur le comportement
de l'humain par rapport à l'humain
il a été il était il était
officier de police et pendant qu'il
était officier de police était la guerre
et donc il a été un militant résistants
de l'intérieur très fort et c'est ce qui
s'est passé dans les années 30
en france il a vu ça de très près de
cette île là il s'est engagé à n'être qu
écrivain il a mangé beaucoup de pain
gris et voilà il est devenu un grand nom
dans la poésie contemporaine
cette exposition réalisée avec la
collaboration de sa fille anne-marie
permet de réunir pour la première fois
romans essais et recueils depuis 1930 à
2009 ainsi que les photos peintures et
collages réalisés par l'artiste aux
multiples facettes
dans le cadre de la 10e édition de
poésie ville organisé par la maison de
la poésie un hommage appuyé lui sera
rendu le vendredi 11 octobre à 20h enfin
de cette édition du 3 octobre
exceptionnellement il n'y aura pas deux
journal demain je vous retrouverai en
revanche lundi en direct à 18h excellent
week end